well now we all know where Jesse Pinkman
was driving to in the series finale of
Breaking Bad need for speed need for
speed stars Aaron Paul and this is the
latest video game - movie adaptation not
always the best sign sometimes doesn't
really work out past examples include
Super Mario Brothers Mortal Kombat
annihilation which I just talked about
in my newest hilarious ax T review so
this movie Aaron Paul plays this really
badass street racer and something goes
really wrong which I will not spoil
which starts a revenge path between him
and this other guy played by Dominic
Cooper so Aaron Paul has to travel
across the country to this big secret
race in which he can finally challenge
this man hopefully take revenge over
what he did and right the wrongs of his
past now I really like Aaron Paul the
guy is a great actor I was a big fan of
Breaking Bad he proved that he can be a
fantastic actor dramatically he's very
funny and he seems like a really nice
guy in real life and he is very good in
this movie because my buddy after the
movie he said you know what I did not
see Jesse Pinkman and this character at
all he played his role really well and I
completely agree with him he owned the
role he was his own character you were
able to separate this from the Breaking
Bad character and that's really great
because Aaron Paul proves here that he's
definitely an actor to watch even though
the movie itself has some problems he is
definitely the bright spot of this movie
along with the fantastic car chases the
car chases in this movie are practical
in-camera stunt work no CGI the director
is clearly a humongous fan of Bullitt
there's even a scene the beginning of
the movie where the characters are at a
drive-in and Bullitt is on the screen
now bullet was a great movie with Steve
McQueen and not just because of the
balls-to-the-wall fantastic car chase
sequence there was a lot of other stuff
in Bullitt that is often overlooked that
made that scene all the more great
because it was just that one huge
awesome scene and even before this movie
started the director and Aaron Paul were
in a live feed introducing it to the
audience and he said I loved Bullitt as
a kid I just wanted to make a movie
about muscle cars with real stunt work
and no CGI because it's becoming a lost
art in Hollywood and I really liked that
mentality the problem is bullet had a
good story and good characters to back
up that awesome chase sequence need for
speed doesn't have those things even
though it tries very hard to give you
good character
and an interesting romance and a lot of
things that would heighten the chase
sequences the problem is the absurdities
of the script and the lackluster
dialogue doesn't really work see there
are so many awesome chase sequences in
this movie and although they are done
very well the fact that there are so
many of them make them seem less
important that one incredible chase
scene in Bullitt the director obviously
wanting to capture that type of
adrenaline the reason it was so great is
because it was just that one scene that
was so incredible they felt like they
actually stood out like they meant
something and need for speed there are
so many of them that they kind of get
lost in the shuffle despite the fact
they are filmed very well now as I said
the characters in the movie aren't
really that interesting even though they
are played as best as they can by some
of these actors another thing I really
liked about this movie was the
ethnically diverse cast that's always
really cool to see it because for sure
this movie is not whitewashed at all
there's lots of different races in this
movie races races car car races and
people races they're all here and that
brings me to something this movie does
kind of copy off the Fast and the
Furious franchise it's trying to emulate
that success in various ways I can tell
there are certain characters in this
movie that feel like they are pulled
right out of the Fast and Furious
franchise and like I said the
absurdities of the story start to weigh
it down like certain characters just
pull army helicopters like out of their
butt like where did you get that where'd
you get that plane where'd you get that
a helicopter this is one characters move
II who's granted a likeable guy but in
the movie he just keeps showing up in
every scene with a new plane of some
kind and you're like this doesn't make
any sense the entire story of having to
go across the country to this race while
outrunning the cops the entire time also
doesn't make any sense there's a aspect
of the story where you are wondering how
this character is actually going to
achieve any type of emotional Redemption
from the bad thing that happened to him
in the past by winning a race it's not
until the third act of the movie where
an opportunity is presented to him out
of the blue that could help him get his
revenge but up until then I'm wondering
what is he doing there like how is he
supposed to get his revenge also they
pick up a character in the middle of the
movie that's supposed to help fix their
car but he doesn't do anything except
make jokes he never fixes their car and
it all just feels like we're trying to
be really entertaining right now but
we're not it's kind of just like they're
putting scenes in there that are
supposed to be fun
need to get you to that next car chase
to fill out the runtime of the movie
which by the way is too long at two
hours and 10 minutes
like I said Aaron Paul is good in this
movie the car chases are impressive I
admire the director for trying to make
really cool scenes here without using
CGI that's awesome but unfortunately the
story and the lackluster characters
didn't really back that up and so it
started to drag a little bit I'm gonna
give need for speed a sea I admire the
cast I admire the director for doing
their best with this material
unfortunately the material itself just
isn't as strong as it should be so guys
if you see the movie if you've played
the games let me know what you thought
below because obviously it's just kind
of a racing game and they had a lot of
room to grow here guys thanks so much
for watching and as always if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck niced
so guys as I told you before in the past
I am currently in the middle of a really
awesome deal with audible.com these guys
really like my videos and they like you
too and they want to give you guys a
free audiobook through me basically all
you got to do if you would like to
listen to a star or a celebrity or a
famous author read their book or a movie
based book like Carrie which I read you
can do that at audible.com and I'm
giving you guys a free download of your
choice you can go there and pick
anything you want
that's audible.com slash Kris they gave
me my own custom URL they want to
support what I'm doing and I think that
is so awesome if you guys want to go to
audible.com slash Kris you can download
any free audio book of your choice
if you'd like to read or if you like to
listen to this stuff while you run or
workout or do whatever you can that is
free to you through me from audible
thanks guys and I hope you check them